try let me ask you this first because we
were debating early on about the merits
of having Dallas and the Lions on
Thanksgiving it's just tradition I
assume but did the NFL lose something by
not trying to find a way to get their
marquee teams that are playing at a high
level on that particular day well I
think that's why I created the third
game yeah so they have the ability to do
that I was in the middle of this when I
was in the lead trying to get it changed
because there was a significant
advantage to playing on thanksgiving day
you had to you had to hunt for the stats
to prove it but uh because Detroit had
played since the thirties or traditional
game but they didn't seem to any
statistical advantage than winning a
losing common sense there to be home on
Thursday you have an edge with it even
has the travel see but he couldn't match
this basically then dallas where it
showed with dallas and it showed more so
about as a one more than the tray was if
you had a winning record okay and you
were home on Thanksgiving you want a
higher percentage of games on
Thanksgiving and ascended more
importantly the game after thanksgiving
to you had to tend a break then you
would otherwise so the others in
advantage so we let a fight that I let a
fighter people who of teams in the
league to get this thing changed and we
could never get a change so uh so it
stayed there it's never gonna change now
but adding the third game I think
satisfies your point which is an
excellent point so you know Charlie I
have our our crack research department
working on those numbers right now
trying to finally there they're very
they're very busy in front of me but
that supple very busy very busy arm did
the Cleveland Browns have a bad day
yesterday uh yes because one of two
things either uh San Francisco took the
quarterback they wanted or it took an
option out for a trade their their their
position became uh I was devalued or not
maybe say maybe they got all that this
is only one quarterback left yeah um but
maybe the teams that wanted to trade
don't do want to trade for when so I
want to trade for Goff so it's hard to
say uh but you'd like to have both
options of both quarterbacks being there
for yourself in the trade you know I
understand people that question the
amount of pics that were given up for by
the Rams to get up to number one people
bring up Herschel Walker people bring up
rg3 but I feel like Charlie when you've
got a young running back like Todd
Gurley and you have the chance to pair
him with one of the marquee quarterbacks
it just makes the risk a little bit more
appetizing to take well is the time
really if you look at their franchise it
there in David stuck in neutral because
they did have a quarterback sam
bradford's could stay healthy yeah but
so they have a quarterback they've got a
playoff defense do you like you say they
got a Pro Bowl running back they've got
the parts their move they move to LA eh
they're gonna sell one year on LA
because it's the first year last year so
because of that la is going to demand a
winner i think the Rams in the Raiders
when they left ravagin 55,000 a game so
it's time to go get a quarterback it's a
bold move yes to the overpaid who knows
whether they overpaid the guy plays well
and they go to the playoffs and they win
with them no one's gonna remember what
they gave up it seems like they're the
the social media it has it's made its
declarations Carson Wentz definitely
going number one he's the guy and his
Jared Goff he's definitely going number
one he's the guy in your opinion as one
quarterback separated himself from the
other yes but uh but but it depends on
where you are standing as a franchise
okay God's more ready to play right now
that's why i think that the Rams will
take uh God has very good instincts
pocket awareness gets the ball out quick
those are his assets is his weaknesses
he does not have a big arm and his
accuracy down the field could could be
better I think then you know with wench
uh Joe Flacco I think he's a better
prospect coming out of college than Joe
Flacco why do I say Joe Flacco same
level of competition Delaware North
Dakota State he's a more athletic Joe
Flacco is what I look at but he tends to
stay on the first read too often and he
throws too many fastballs he don't have
enough change ups in there when he needs
it see his touches in his good all the
time is what we're saying so he's
farther away both
these guys have to adjust the calling
plays in the huddle Goff evidently did
high school once has so far as I know
anyway uh so it kind of depends where
your team is if you got a good team and
you can can work around the quarterback
in like Roethlisberger and Flacco the
defense in the running game can win it
for you say Louis might be like that you
could afford to take wench if you need a
guy's got to give you a little bit
quicker production a goth can do that I
think they go with copies of Wesley's a
West Coast guys that familiarity this
team this team is overweight now I sense
that it's time to move and I think
that's why they picked off but I like
whence overall if you got a little time
to work with good to visit with you
Charlie I appreciate the time Gregory
buddy now that's Charley Casserly NFL
Network longtime NFL executive here on
the program the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience